So the type of magic I like,
and I'm a magician,
is magic that uses technology
to create illusions.
So I would like to show you
something I've been working on.
It's an application
that I think will be useful for artists --
multimedia artists in particular.
It synchronizes videos
across multiple screens of mobile devices.
I borrowed these three iPods
from people here in the audience
to show you what I mean.
And I'm going to use them to tell you
a little bit about my favorite subject:
deception.
(Music)
One of my favorite magicians
is Karl Germain.
He had this wonderful trick
where a rosebush would bloom
right in front of your eyes.
But it was his production of a butterfly
that was the most beautiful.
(Recording) Announcer:
Ladies and gentlemen,
the creation of life.
(Applause)
(Music)
Marco Tempest: When asked about deception,
he said this:
Announcer: Magic
is the only honest profession.
A magician promises to deceive you --
and he does.
MT: I like to think of myself
as an honest magician.
I use a lot of tricks,
which means that sometimes
I have to lie to you.
Now I feel bad about that.
But people lie every day.
(Ringing)
Hold on.
Phone: Hey, where are you?
MT: Stuck in traffic. I'll be there soon.
You've all done it.
(Laughter)
(Music)
Right: I'll be ready
in just a minute, darling.
Center: It's just what I've always wanted.
Left: You were great.
MT: Deception,
it's a fundamental part of life.
Now polls show
that men tell twice
as many lies as women --
assuming the women
they asked told the truth.
(Laughing)
We deceive to gain advantage
and to hide our weaknesses.
The Chinese general Sun Tzu said
that all war was based on deception.
Oscar Wilde said
the same thing of romance.
Some people deceive
for money.
Let's play a game.
Three cards, three chances.
Announcer: One five will get you 10,
10 will get you 20.
Now, where's the lady?
Where is the queen?
MT: This one?
Sorry. You lose.
Well, I didn't deceive you.
You deceived yourself.
Self-deception.
That's when we convince ourselves
that a lie is the truth.
Sometimes it's hard to tell the two apart.
Compulsive gamblers
are experts at self-deception.
(Slot machine)
They believe they can win.
They forget the times they lose.
The brain is very good at forgetting.
Bad experiences are quickly forgotten.
Bad experiences quickly disappear.
Which is why in this vast
and lonely cosmos,
we are so wonderfully optimistic.
Our self-deception
becomes a positive illusion --
why movies are able to take us
onto extraordinary adventures;
why we believe Romeo
when he says he loves Juliet;
and why single notes of music,
when played together,
become a sonata and conjure up meaning.
That's "Clair De lune."
Its composer, called Debussy,
said that art was
the greatest deception of all.
Art is a deception
that creates real emotions --
a lie that creates a truth.
And when you give yourself
over to that deception,
it becomes magic.
[MAGIC]
(Music fades slowly)
(Applause)
Thank you. Thank you very much.